[Music]  so why did you leave illinois  how did i leave illinois  honestly i left because  job opportunity i was right not for real  i was working  tysons and then the lady i was seeing i  didn't want to do nothing with her she  was a piece of [ __ ] she was a leech she  didn't want to do nothing she didn't  want to work she just want to have kids  not by me but other guys and i post to  take care of them kids as a man and i'm  still young living with my best days and  i don't think i'm supposed to take care  of the next male responsibility but i do  post to do so i left because me and her  was not  so she drove you out of illinois no i  drove myself  what you mean as drove  me i drove myself out of illinois if she  drove me